comme je suis beaucoup fatigué j'aime
mieux être en tête que d'être en
activité le matin je me lève le plus
tard possible pour que la journée soit
le moins longue possible né en 1915
Charles a toujours été proche de la
nature il a même quelques secrets de
longévité
l'hiver avec une camomille dedans la
camomille qu'on fabriquait mais comme la
fiscalité nous a réduit à ne plus
distiller
et ben on peut plus mettre de camomille
dans le tilleul
la camomille
il apporte bien saisi le monsieur hein
ça ranime l'organisme et puis ça le fait
aller plus loin dans la vie ici ça va
être l'avenir de la salade chicorée
scarole il faut pas s'employer à quelque
chose si on veut rester
actif autrement pour que la cuisine soit
bonne il faut des oignons dedans
autrement c'est de la cuisine de techno
[Rires]